[Music]
there are six Titans to jump into in
titanfall 2 but which one is right for
you
well depending on the game mode map
layout and of course your play style you
may be switching Titan seats often so
let's break down each one of these hunks
of metal and find out what they're made
of
her name is ion reliable and
well-balanced she's a standard choice
but there's something unique about her
ions abilities share one energy resource
meaning every move you make except for
your primary fire and core ability will
drain from one cool down even your
alternate zoom fire will take energy
it's all about power management with ion
so avoid charging a full laser shot and
a retreat save that energy for your
vortex shield or mine's noteworthy ion
kits are entangled energy which restores
energy from critical hits with your
primary gun or there's the zero point
kit which lets tripmines cost zero
energy allowing you to put even more
power into your laser shot which is the
real moneymaker
other than that iron's laser core is
pretty straightforward try to engage it
on any cover less tighten you got tone
Fox - that's right tones all about the
home you're striving to see that white
turn red and then let them rip
her primary tracker Canon offers great
distance and when you combo that with
her particle wall she's a prime
long-distance choice and it's her
particle wall that makes her a team
player drop it down for all to shoot
through she's your girl when handling
those tight lanes especially when you
consider her ability to curve rockets
around corners launching her sonar lock
downfield doesn't just reveal enemies it
grants a partial Titan lock-on allowing
you to literally curve missiles around
obstacles if you're into that double
down on the length of the sonar with a
pulse echo kit using her salvo court
further defies obstacles just consider
launching those guided rockets in open
areas
you got the two big guys Legion is a
beast to say the least he's in the thick
of it dishing damage this tank's minigun
takes a second to warm up so do so prior
to peeking around from cover speaking of
which switching fire modes does take
time as well be mindful of your
surroundings with Legion and try to
predict when to switch between long and
short range not just because you're
getting more precise kills but because
your other ability the power shot relies
on it in close range the power shot
knocks back enemies and the long range
power shot launches a heated ball of
damage you got a gun shield and it's
clutch for hairy situations just
remember to engage it before you go ham
with a smart core and my god it is all
about the smart coil why it locks on to
everything making it perfect for mopping
up grunts and bounty hunt not only that
if you force a pilot to eject with it
let's just say they won't be landing
Scorch is your other moneymaker for
modes with grunts due to his great area
of effect and that's all thanks to his
ability to launch ignitable gas traps
your primary thermite launchers fire
rate is slow so do your best to tray it
off with your firewall in order to
ignite traps but knowing when and where
to ignite traps is the tricky part
no the titan you're up against run into
a North Star
chances are she's going to bounce out in
which case launch and ignite a gas trap
behind them and push them into it see ya
Ronan closing in spark one right in
front of you and lure them into it do
your best to save a trap when unleashing
flame core to inflict mass damage and
when it comes to countering a pilot's
grapple your flame shield is the perfect
answer Ronan the ninja his broadsword is
enticing but you must fight the urge to
match that melee you are the hit-and-run
tactician
hence the phase - warp out of existence
to sneak out of sticky situations and
most definitely use it to gain
unsuspecting grounds your armor is weak
and everyone else knows that so your
dashing through the cover of narrow
lanes avoiding the wide open ranges but
no matter what you'll find yourself
squared off with the Titan you need to
close that gap as soon as possible and
get in there Grill strive for agility
and speed consider adding turbo engine
for a third - and parry with your sword
block when you run out of speed if
you're close enough sending off an arc
wave will stun a tightening giving you
ample time to constantly circle your foe
swinging and if you got that sword core
ready you're golden
finally there's North Star just like
Ronan she lacks armor meaning you two
are practicing guerrilla tactics only
the difference is you live for distance
you're a sniper with a plus you can
hover charge up that railgun and hit
that VTOL four shots that no one else
can make
do hammer tightens with a fully charged
rail gunshot but for pilots they don't
deserve it
it's a great Titan for hunting pilots
and CTF but again you are not meant for
the frontlines North Star has
practically no defense so when a Titan
is closing in you drop that tether trap
to slow them down and send off a cluster
missile better yet
tack on the enhanced payload kit to make
that missile even more lethal because
all you can really do in a retreat is
attack however when your flight Corps is
ready shall them
show them off
and there you have it some pointers and
mastering the lineup of mechs and
titanfall - what's your favorite of the
lot and if you have any tips or pointers
on them do leave them in the comment
section below
thanks for watching and for all things
titanfall stay tuned to games bye
you